i've interviewed over 400 comedians and
this is the number one piece of advice
the main thing is always try to get as
much stage time as you can i mean a lot
of times people
just want to make it and they have a
couple of jokes and they and they kill
it whenever they go on stage and they
believe like that's all that it takes
but really the more that you sharpen
your knife your machete whatever it is
that you when you're on that stage and
have that ability to walk out there uh
is something that i you know always
recommend comedy is a language and the
stage is your submersion but don't take
my word for it go listen to hot breath
podcast where